you're having a movie marathon each
movie lasts about 1 and 3 4 hours if you
want to watch three movies how long will
your movie marathon last you can use the
number line below to help you find your
answer so each movie lasts one and three
four or one and three fourths hours long
so let's say the first movie so let's
say the first movie happens to be star
wars which i probably would include in
any movie marathon so it's going to be
one and three fourths hours long so this
is let's see this is one
one and then we're going to have three
fourths more so each of these are a
fourth because we have four sections
between one and two one two three four
so we're gonna watch three fourths one
two three so that's how long my first
movie is
and then my second movie is going to be
another one and three-fourths so one is
four-fourths so one two three four and
then we're gonna have another
three-fourths one two three and this is
the way i said that four fourths and
three fourths is seven fourths so one
and three fourths that's the same thing
as seven fourths and you see that over
here when i did the one and three
fourths in blue i actually marked off
seven fourths same thing here
here in magenta and now let's do it in
green so
gandhi is actually a good bit longer
than one and three fourths but it's a
good movie so i i put it here just
because one of my favorite and so let's
do another one and three fourths hours
so or we could do that is four fourths
plus three fourths hours or seven
fourths one
two three four five six seven
so that gets us that gets us to
5 so this point right over here
is
and 1 4 hours let's see if we got that
same
if we get the same result when we do it
when we do it mathematically i guess
this is mathematical as well
but every movie lasts one and three
fourths hours we already said that one
and three-fourths is the same thing as
one plus three-fourths
is the same thing one is the same thing
as four-fourths so it's four-fourths
plus three-fourths which is the same
thing as seven-fourths and another way
to convert this mixed number into an
improper fraction you say hey look four
times one is four and that's really
where you're getting the four-fourths
from plus three is seven
seven fourths now we're gonna we're
gonna do seven fourths of an hour three
times so we're gonna multiply seven
fourths
seven fourths
times three
times three now there's several ways
that you could think about this you
could literally view this as having
seven three seven fourths and adding
them together
so seven fourths plus seven fourths
plus seven fourths
which would be equal to 21 over 4 and if
you wanted to convert this into a mixed
number 21 over 4 is the same thing as
well 4 goes into 20 evenly so you could
call this 20 over 4 plus 1 over 4 and 20
over 4 is the same thing as 5. so it's
five and one
five and one fourth which is exactly
what we saw here another way of thinking
about it you could say
seven fourths and then we can multiply
it by three over one
times three
over 1. just to make it clear that we're
multiplying the numerators and
multiplying the denominators so in the
numerator i'm going to have 7 plus 7
plus 7. that's 7 times 3 and the
denominator i'm going to have 4 times 1
which is just 4. well this is just 7
times 3
over 4 or 21 over 4 which we've already
seen is 5
and 1 4.